Wow there's a mod look yeah yes nice
thank you
that bell-bottom thing yeah cool well
listen you're you're doing sign out live
now right but you're off this week
they're not doing a show yes we have a
week uh I'm very excited yeah what are
you doing with yourself uh well I went
dancing last night I went out to a dance
club do you ever go to dance clubs no no
I never usually go you know it's
embarrassing for me you know cuz I
tap-dance you never see that in the club
so you want to dance sure you seem cool
about the whole thing no no actually it
wasn't that bad I I met a guy there and
he was really nice
and uh we talked for a while he asked me
for my phone number you know and I gave
him a fake number but I felt really bad
about it so I moved there actually you
two are very happy now oh yes we're very
happy actually yeah this week was a lot
of fun a friend of mine took me to a
queer nation rally yeah have you ever
been that I had a lot of fun it was
really good it was really I
misunderstood him actually when he
invited me I thought he said claymation
rally so I was walking around with a
sign that said I love Davey and Goliath
great there are a lot of them here
tonight now listen now I understand
Congress claymation fans I understand
that okay yeah I understand
congratulations are in order the friend
you have a new apartment right yeah I
just moved into a new apartment in the
East Village and and it's good it's
already really disgusting though
actually it's really dirty you know like
the kitchen floor is sticky I don't know
how it got that way that's gross I had
to do something about it you know so
finally I got some slippers that's
working out good yeah I'm gonna get some
boots some planning on going to the
bathroom you paint a very pretty picture
yeah and we decorated way too early of
course you know we which is I think
everybody does we painted every wall of
our apartment dark purple yeah on a whim
you know but we had to to match the bong
[Applause]
youthful or something and we this is
obnoxious we got our cat stoned a while
ago
you gotta on marijuana stoned yeah so
rude he ran away the next day really why
I don't know I'm not so bad about it
until about a month ago I saw him at a
Grateful Dead show
who's selling bean sandwiches I couldn't
even take him home you know cuz he was
touring he's done well without you
Thanks I'm sorry no I think Billy no no
now you've been now how long you been
here you're from originally you're from
New Hampshire yeah alright now you've
been here so how long like four and a
half years four and a half years I've
been living in New York and I love it
here it's great I am made a lot of
friends I saw my friend Alan today and
it was good to see him cuz I've been
really busy and he's been busy and he
had a testicle removed yeah
a while ago have you ever had it tested
I thought about it and then it must be
horrific yeah to have a testicle removed
yeah
but you get along with him you have a
good time so he's a he's an optimist
this guy he's so optimistic he says he
thinks of his scrotum as half-full
good attitude
I ended up going out with them
really yeah yeah and it was okay I had a
ball
time is what I'm trying to say yes these
are all very pleasant antics
listen we're gonna we're gonna step away
for a bit and we'll be right back with
Jamiroquai so thank you